-Guest tonight from films
such as "Notting Hill,"
"Love Actually," and "Four
Weddings and a Funeral,"
he currently stars in HBO'
limited series "The Undoing,
which airs Sundays at 9:00 PM.
Let's take a look.
-Why were you there that night
Outside her apartment?
-Because I was -- I was walking,
like I always do.
I didn't know where I was.
I've told you this many times.
-It is just such a coincidence
isn't it, though?
I was having an affair with her,
and you were there
just as I was or just had been
-What are you asking me?
-Were you following me?
♪♪♪♪
-Was I following you?
-Were you?
Were you following me?
-Please welcome back
to the show, Hugh Grant.
How are you, Hugh?
-Very bad, thank you, Seth
-[ Chuckles ] Are you --
I mean, junkets are not the most
fun thing in the world.
Do you appreciate --
Do you enjoy
that you just get to do it
from home?
-Not at all.
I'm trying to get away from home
permanently.
-[ Laughs ]
-I have a lot of young children.
I love them, but I would lov
to be on an airplane
coming to see you
and staying in a lovely hotel.
-That's very nice to hear.
I'll take that as not a
criticism of your children
but more how much you enjoy ou
time together.
-You specifically, yes. Yes.
-[ Chuckles ]
What -- This is
such a wonderful show.
It's the show that not onl
are my wife and I watching
but I feel like we talk to wit
all our other friends.
And this is a show
I was very happy to hear
that your wife
actually enjoys as well.
-It's weird.
First of all, it's lovely
that you're watching it.
I almost believe you.
-[ Chuckles ]
[ Laughter ]
-My wife, yes, she -- My wife is
the man in our house, really
She likes violent films,
gangster films,
while I'm sitting there watching
"Roman Holiday" or
"Sound of Music" or something.
So she's never liked
those films I did in the past,
which were, you know,
all romance and stuff.
But now -- Now she's startin
to get a taste for them,
and she did like this series
I have to say.
Though, not so much me.
More she's in love with
the murdered lady's husband,
you know,
played by Ismael Cruz Cordova.
And she's very in love wit
the cop, Edgar Ramírez's part.
-Yeah. We had Edgar here.
I can see how she would
fall in love with him.
Very charming.
-Yeah.
-[ Chuckles ]
-If you like that kind of thing.
[ Laughter ]
-Now, I mean this seriously,
do you keep the -- you know,
this is a fantastic whodunit
You obviously know who done it
Do you keep that from your wife,
or does she beg you
for the spoiler?
-She did know, because
although she's not intereste
in show business
in any way at all,
she -- I bore her about all my
work, and so I, you know,
took her through all the scripts
and all the issues
before we started.
But you're making me nervous
You're bringing me towards
precipices of...
destroying my own show.
-I don't want it.
I don't want to ruin it.
I feel like -- It's weird.
I was saying this
to someone else.
I feel like it says a lot abou
the time we're living throug
that I like the escapism
of watching a show
about a grizzly murder.
But I wouldn't want to do
nothing to ruin it for myself.
-Yeah, good. Good.
It is weird, isn't it?
It's weird.
-It is. It's just like --
I think it's also knowing
that the show --
because it's a limited series --
it's just nice to engage i
anything right now
that you know has an ending.
-Yes! Yes, I know exactly
what you mean.
That's maybe why I do so badly
with TV.
I can't really watch it.
I have to watch, you know,
a single game of tennis
or something.
Everything's too long.
It's too long for me now.
[ Indistinct ]
-Well, you've been giving us -
'cause you were in
a fantastic limited series
the last time you were here.
I want to make sure
I get it right.
Was it "A British Scandal"
or "An English Scandal"?
-"A Very English Scandal," yes
-Which was, again, fantastic
I loved it so much,
and I also loved going into it
I'm like, "Three episodes?
Thank you very much.
This is exactly
where I want to be."
-Yeah, well, I agree with you.
But then I think our attention
spans have shrunk dramatically
-Well, I also have
young children.
I think that has a --
plays a huge role.
-How old are yours?
-Two and four.
-Yeah? Well,
I have one of each of those.
-You do?
-How old are you, though?
-How old am I? I'm 46.
-Yeah, that seems about right.
-Yeah.
-People say we look alike.
-[ Chuckles ]
-You still look pretty good.
Twitter says I look like
a piece of crumpled newspaper.
-[ Laughs ]
You can't engage with that
Don't listen to them.